and go ahead and shop
to sort of frame this we this is a
continuation you can go ahead and shop
please
yep
and go ahead
as i said sort of framed this this is a
continuation of a meeting from a couple
weeks ago and that one we kind of
focused on more low-level stuff like
language design
but now we kind of
have the higher level
notebook interface workflows
more importantly so people joining this
live stream we should explain what an
office is about okay
uh question would you like me to go
are we live i didn't even yeah okay
great
um right so this is a new framework
that's coming out in wolfram language
for
writing questions like uh like
educational
questions like in a quiz for students
that have automatic assessment built in
and the idea is
you can package these things into get
together in notebooks to make quizzes
and
you know there's a there's a deployment
mechanism to the cloud
that secures the answer keys and you can
distribute
quizzes that way and students can answer
them
um and let's see the whole workflow it's
all very general yeah so this is like
the top-level workflow and anybody who
watched last week including us uh we saw
sort of like from the ground up like the
language design of things that empowers
us and we'll probably work our way back
to there
in this meeting i'd hope
uh but it's good to have it okay so this
thing then makes this let's let's start
with what it makes could i see what it
makes please
so what it makes is
equip it
can you just show it
like this
here's the quiz right here okay let's
zoom in a bit
no you don't yeah it makes you don't
need to it's fine it makes a quiz that
we can answer
why does that have a little
but do we have somebody from graphic
design here we please get somebody from
graphic design
we're going to have a bunch of graphic
designers too
okay yeah
i don't know why that check mark has a
has a broken box there
why does that check mark have a broken
box right uh that's the asset that we
have where did it come from from from
design yeah
we looked at a bunch of them we said i
don't understand why we would have that
one it just looks broken to me
i think sure i think yeah i think other
people thought it looked nice
i i yeah i don't have a any
justification it looks like it looked to
me like it was you know it had some kind
of
you know pixeloid problem yeah i don't
have a screen maybe if you complete the
square it looks kind of weird or
something i don't know i don't know i
think it's yeah it looks a bit modern i
guess i don't know
okay
so that math quiz thing is that can you
show me on the in the source where that
comes from
the thing that says math quiz that's
here in the settings menu
so i'm not sure that's styling so i see
so that styling
you've got to say more than just dark
cell
got to say
yep um because that's in compounds yeah
that's the wrong label it should be
title
quiz title
right
yeah titled paren docked at the top of
the screen or something yeah is it
docked at the top of the screen yes
yeah yeah if there were if there were 20
questions it would scroll with it
so question um is the
if i wanted to put additional things in
there that said things like you know
answer seven of the ten questions or
something
if i want to put additional material
there
i would like to be able to do that
rather than just having that that
i mean obviously you can put arbitrary
content in the notebook itself yeah yeah
um exactly
you know i understand that but that that
non-scrollable
you know that dark cell
yeah it's just meant to be like a simple
kind of thing but
um
i know it's a simple thing it also
doesn't look very good no it doesn't
yeah the spacing above it is definitely
two yeah the spacing is a little weird
yeah i'm not sure about that are we
getting colors fine
design
anybody from design please since
graphic design review we should have
graphic design
yeah i'm tracking something down right
now
okay
make your window narrower
no no just
that window the there is the aren't the
the the quiz window just make it much
narrower
are you doing that i'm not seeing
anything yep i'm doing that well i'm not
seeing anything yeah i'm not oh there it
goes
i think zoom was just slow to respond
okay
so how does this work on mobile does it
go responsive correctly
yeah it's just a cloud notebook and uh
yeah i think that
cloud objects are asking a specific
question does it because you know we do
have some capability
i mean if i look at this on my phone is
it going to look decent
have you looked i haven't no i haven't
looked on mobile you need to check that
yep
okay
um
and has this had any kind of ux review
is anybody from ux in this meeting
this hasn't the original you know the
standard form notebooks did and we've
you know used a lot of
that precedent to design this but it
hasn't been reviewed in the question so
it needs to be i agree yeah okay
all right so let's come back so this is
what we're making
and when we press submit here
what's happening
you mean we're
so there's two i mean
right if you see in this settings menu
before you key closes it yeah it was
going to look in the settings right so
in the settings menu you have the choice
for things to be assessed locally or in
the cloud
right so if it's locally
it's not really secure a clever person
can find the answer key and answer it
but if it's in the cloud
then when you press submit it sends your
answer along with a question id to an
endpoint that was created in the cloud
when you hit generate
and there the assessment runs and it
returns an assessment result object
saying whether you're correct or
incorrect there might be like an
explanation
that sort of stuff and then right let's
think about the wording answer key
contained in notebook
did we did we confirm that wording
earlier
i
i think we came up with in a meeting
with you but yeah
i don't
you know we could revisit it certainly
the question is what notebook means
because
um
what do we call the sort of client
notebook
we usually call this the authoring and
then this one the user
notebook
inform really we've called a quiz
notebook which just makes a lot of sense
but then but you know then we're buying
into the term quiz which we can do i
don't know i don't think but it's it's
not necessarily general enough
um
[Music]
yeah user notebook is general enough but
it maybe isn't specific enough
um
answer key content
the problem is which notebook are we
talking about here right and yeah um
user we could say in user notebook
i'm glad that would help
okay if you continue to use a notebook
sure is contained the right word or
should it say like
encoded
it's not like it's not like they're in
plain text or something to see it yeah
you have to be a little clever that's
saying okay
okay
and use the notebook i think that's good
sure
so we're changing dot cell to say
um
um
title cell i guess
um
oh jeremy did you just join us
yeah i just joined
um
stephen could you show the um
uh the the
the thing on the right that the user
notebook whatever we're calling it
jeremy i am not into the broken box
check marks
this guy right here
okay yeah
all right
i mean
are you going to argue for them no
okay
i mean i think i think that the and i
also think that the green and red should
go more brightly green and red i would
think
i don't really see why they should be
muted like that
i don't know yeah not pure green red but
no definitely the green's a little muted
yeah for sure the reds kind of pops
enough
i know the green is like great you got
it right exactly yeah i agree
okay and a minor point though not for
you jeremy but but um
there's clearly an alignment problem
with that box and the input
field
right
yeah
and that they're alignment problems also
that we see in the input fields and the
settings menu
yeah yeah yeah
i assume billy's i think billy worked on
this he's got a spec this this surely
doesn't match it
okay
um
when i use this to match some of the
eliminations okay so actually there's a
there's a player
ethan our livestream is commenting on
when you say assess each question
independently or assess all questions at
once
you should clarify that that means the
first one of those means there's going
to be a submit button on every question
right and the last and the second so
it's not obvious that they assess every
question independently
um
independently paren
you know submit button for each question
include a submit button on each question
for each question and last one
you know
how about if it was just submit each
question independently
with that yes that's better that's
better okay yeah submit all questions at
once
right yeah that's better
[Music]
um and the ella wants to submit buttons
up in the dark cell as well right
stephen yeah yeah well one submit is up
here
oh it is it's not down at the bottom
no
okay i think we should flip around
um
i think those two things little little
orphans at the bottom there should be
probably be before they assess locally
or in the cloud i mean for us it's
important whether it's local or in the
cloud but i have to say i think that's a
detail for many people using this
okay
i think this is a much more
um
i would flip them around unless you
object to that sure nope
okay
all right so let's come back
um the dark cell
oh sure
why aren't you just letting them since
you've you we have form notebook
technology why not just let them enter a
cell there
just put in a cell
they can
what's that
yeah yeah we could um
i don't see why not because i think
people are going to want to put all
kinds of random stuff there
even multiple cells because i think
people are going to want things like you
know you're allowed to use a calculator
on this test which is kind of a
ridiculous idea for
the thing being done on a computer but
you know or
you know
you have 15 minutes for this section
i think people often want to put that in
the header at the top rather than i
would think
i mean what do i know i haven't taken a
test in millions of years yeah i mean i
think you know the timing thing is
something we want to build in in the
next is the next set of features
um so you wouldn't be writing that out
yourselves i think you could just be
using a built-in system for that
okay fine but i mean i'm saying i don't
see any reason why we have the
technology
to let them put anything they want there
i think they're going to want to put
different things there you know they
don't want to put they might want to put
the logo of the of the school or
something like that there who knows
yeah i guess the idea
behind this is to just keep it
simple i know
i'm not sure people want it simple i
mean if you just have a cell there they
can type anything they want into that is
simple for them
and it will be by default and have some
particular style
yeah i think the multiple sales thing
would be pretty tricky to do okay so
and then
just have it be there and in the build
um
um
okay
okay let's go back
uh this to the source please
okay what is question generator
right so that's the new symbol we're
introducing thirteen one that we talked
about a couple weeks ago
um where you basically have a
parameterized question object and you're
specifying a parameter space
what's question pool do we get to swim
in it
uh
if you're not doing very well you might
feel that way
so i mean question pool is just like uh
a pre-defined set of question objects
that is
you know it randomly serves one to
each student
yeah
i don't understand what happens that's
in the authoring notebook what do i do
so you can edit it by clicking edit
question pool
and then you add whatever questions you
want to the pool
and then when you're
generating it into the user notebook
then the user gets one of those one or
more what does it look like in there
what does it look like
in the authoring notebook when you have
a pool question
it's this right and then that so we have
like this pop-up that collapses back
down into what we're looking at yeah
the goal is to have a pop-up for the
generators listen you're not inserting a
question pool you're inserting an
instance of the question pool
and you're not inserting a question
generator
you're not inserting
i think you
are
yeah i think in the same way that you're
inserting a question object you're
inserting a question generator or
question let me see the pull down of the
question thing
that's
nice yeah
and what's the difference in multiple
what's question versus multiple choice
oh i see those are yeah so these are the
uh
options that i've already chosen yeah
the recently used
that's confusing yeah that's a big
probably should be a
delicious vertical delay yeah there's
probably a design solution to make it i
think those should look a little
different than the other buttons these
ones yeah yeah sure
i mean we could have the the ones the
first three have some color behind them
and the buttons and those last two be
white
like i don't know i'm having a yellow
day today
i don't know i'm in my steven meeting
um
uh we can also have little icons for
pool and generator
um
yes that might help like you know
obviously
gears come to mind for generators
there's lots of gears yeah yeah that's
obviously the first thing that comes to
mind but
um
yeah
let me think about this for a second so
look you know what maybe we should have
that first thing be called single
question
and then question pool question
generator
no
that's stupid
um
specific question
because they're all inserting a question
question pool and question generator are
all questions for the toward to the end
users yeah yeah they're concerning a
question for the end user so what's the
difference to the author the author is a
specific question just a specific
question or you know
static
predefined
um well they're predefined they'll think
it's defined before them
yeah as opposed to
well we could say static or fixed
questions static questions fixed i like
fixed
yeah
i think six is better than simple
questions okay so we could have fixed
question pooled question and generated
question
fixed question random question generated
question
or we could just say question object
no because that's what this is
yeah i mean the generators are often
random depending on
how you're writing them
but that's okay
i would say fixed question random
question generated question
would be not completely obscure
i don't hate it i don't love random
questions but
i don't know
it's a random choice question but that's
too elaborate it's a lot of words
um let's see
sampled random
uh
selected question
announced obscure
[Music]
i think we should go with a random
question
yeah i don't hate it yeah well
randomized question
sounds more like a generator doesn't it
but randomized
is from a pool
okay
fixed question randomized question
generated question
i think that's reasonable random
suggests it could be out in the you know
it could
yeah
yeah yeah
i yeah i'm getting what you mean
it seems freaky yeah it's just all about
where you would assume it's randomized
from i guess
yes all right okay what's next um that's
under insert so we've reviewed the
questions because they've been reviewed
elsewhere right
those those question icons look really
nice
yeah yeah
although true false doesn't want to say
true slash false or something
i think it should say true slash false
rather than
you see what i'm saying
sure yeah
okay tools
so this is the
um
like method that you can use to like
make it so that it's these these are
both things that we've reviewed before
in form notebooks and they're literally
just like copied from form notebook so
but they're obscure in this case because
in a form notebook you don't have this
question stuff of right
i wouldn't say i think they're sort of
the same thing exactly i know the same
thing but in the double decker there
they're looking pretty weird they should
look different than the ones above
yeah
right
and that should be some
i mean i don't what is an information
box anyway
it's these little guys
sorry which
it just added this little more info
thing
yeah collapsed it's collapsible in the
user notebook i don't understand why
these are tools any more than anything
else is a tool i mean these are things
to insert aren't they annotations and
information boxes are yet more things to
insert
see what i'm saying yeah i guess it's
yeah
i guess they're they need to be
differentiated somehow well i mean it
could be called extras or something
right we could put on we could get rid
of the recently used things and put them
all in one line
i like recently i think it's useful
what about if we have four things across
built in then adding recently
what about this what about saying
insert question
instead of insert insert question
and then instead of tools insert extras
yeah
i think it's a yeah that's i think it's
more clear
yeah i'll i'll think on if there's a
better term than extras but yeah i like
it can i'm just a good place to start
for sure
and and then some color coding of the
you know the extras and the
you know how much color coding but they
need to i mean this as it is right now
it's rather hard to understand well
we're recording this we'll make sure
billy gets it and i'm sure he can
propose colors
we're also meeting with billy tomorrow
so we can
talk to him
all right okay what's next here
so show me what happens
if you now
okay so the
that that question pool has got to be
labeled
this is the frame area yes this has got
to be labeled this is utterly obscure
other than that it's blue like a
swimming pool i mean it's just utterly
okay
is there a function called question pool
yes in 13 1 question generator and
question pool are new symbols
okay so why isn't this question pool of
these things
it is
well why does it oh why does it just
look like that that
you know it's all trying to be very
gooey like
yeah and it's not just because you
if you have
like well you could say it could appear
as like question pool of these iconized
yes
yes that's what it should be
yeah
and i don't think you should say edit
question pool i think you should say
edit
edit question list or something
edit questions
no because that be an individual
question because you can add things to
the list
now where do you define that that pool
in the first place
in their popup
yeah why the heck are we doing it that
way
because we're doing it in the notebook
on that you know i know what if you want
on the rectangle cool what if you want
to have
what happens if you want six questions
all
randomly chosen with no duplicates from
this list
yeah so there should be a little option
in here
or it could be also in here where you
say how many
okay
so to me
um
right so it's just got to say question
pool there but i'm also wondering
if our live stream is commenting on the
preview versus code and the color
backgrounds there
yeah it's a good question if you flip
that to preview what does it look like
flip one of those to
preview so this shows you what it will
look like in the
user notebook
right
and then we're rolling out a third
toggle which is gui
where
for cert for some question types you
know you don't have to see code at all
the teacher doesn't even have to yeah
they can just put in the
text for the prompt and the choices and
i think multiple choice
has that in 13 1 but we're on a
development branch here so we're not
seeing it
right
um
okay
so again
uh
all right i mean this is slightly
obscure by the fact that
that you might very well have text
between these questions
sure yeah right
what is that obscure
oh
ethan i now understand eaton's point
that it's not clear what's selected and
what's not right right right is is gray
selected or is white selected
ray being selected is kind of ridiculous
right that was
that was from design
jeremy do you have insight on that no we
just add a touch of color and then i
think it's obvious so yeah
maybe blue maybe not that bright blue
but i think any touch of color would be
obvious there
okay
okay
um
all right so question pool is going to
have that explicit name there and it's
going to say
edit
question space list i would say
that's what i write
yeah
okay now now again what happens if i
want to reuse that same pool i guess one
isn't likely to want to do that because
just you know you might end up answering
asking the same question twice and
stupid stuff like that
so we're making the assumption that
you're not going to want to have
you know
like
i don't think that's stupid i think
people you know like duolingo asks you
the same question three times in a quiz
you know that people do that
really yeah
i think we talked about having some kind
of mechanism for being able to have like
a question pool that was shared
so that you could have multiple that
would complement the same thing but yeah
it's complicated yeah you could have
like a reference to
another question pool in the same yeah
that's that's not in 13 1 but we've
talked about that idea okay
all right fine
okay what's next too
um do we want to look at that rough
wireframe
thing do you want to share included or
yeah
that's on the agenda
okay
maybe you can share both
no i can chat to you
if you've sent me the agenda
so i mean just like we had that pop-up
for question pool we're planning to do
one for the generators
and it's
trickier uh
and we're borrowing from what our
you know consulting group has learned on
some projects
that are similar to this
for that design
um so basically instead of
the pop-up just being a list of
questions you need to specify parameter
space
um
okay so what is this right so so
this is
what what we want to do in the authoring
notebook when you say question generator
like where now we have that question
pool where it's iconized things and then
you can open the pop-up we want to do
the same thing for question generator
so you say question generator opens to
pop-up and you get this thing at the top
and you select question type you say
multiple choice
um
and then and then you get this
the second one where you specify these
are my parameter names
and
then you can use the
gui interface like we have for you know
the static question objects
um to to write your question
and we have this feature that's close to
what the consulting group uses and
there's where
that parameter slot i don't love that
name but it's a button where basically
right so like name is the name of a
parameter so then you would highlight
where it says name in the prompt and you
would
click parameter slot and it would mark
it as a thing to be replaced with the
generated value oh god this is just
unbelievably correct why aren't we just
writing code well certainly i mean you
have to toggle you can change the toggle
to code and just write code
right yeah the idea is to just offer it
as a some make it understandable for
someone
who would prefer not to do it in coding
yeah that's a theory
i mean it's a theory that there are such
people
i'm not sure that they're that that's
really true i mean it reminds me of the
api the absolute disaster of making that
um gui for our api system
just nobody cared it was incredibly hard
to make and nobody cared
yeah
um why are we doing this i mean
it
you know this is what we learned is
useful from no we learned people asked
for we didn't learn well i mean
we don't have anybody there um but
you know danny finn was definitely
definitely thought this was a
opened up the ability to write things to
lots of people
um
i don't know
i don't understand maybe maybe okay try
it again on me i didn't understand what
you said
so right so you're uh you know you're
the teacher teaching class and
you know you're not very strong and well
from language no no i i don't care about
the preamble i care about what is the
functionality of your job right
so so you put in the parameters the code
you're trying to write you're trying to
write a question generator so i'm trying
to write a question generator i just
pasted one in chat
well could you bring that up okay oh i'm
i'm showing
okay
okay
so the issue is so now what are you
actually going in this particular case
where is the code there's got to be code
somewhere it's got somewhere it's got to
have these you would be able to write
this
without code
so you would so right
in the
screenshot at the bottom name would be a
random reel would be you know random
reel a thousand or whatever
and
you then in
the you know one of the slots you would
put floor of a
and then you'd use the parameter slot
button on both a's
and then you could fill and then you
could write whatever you want the you
know wrong answers to be
so what it saves you from is from doing
like string formatting stuff and using
slot
i don't know why you're using two string
i don't know why you're not using string
templates right this would be
implemented via string template well why
isn't that question interface that
you've got up there use a string
template
the whole thing is inside a pure
function right
use a string template there
okay so look here's what i think you
might have to tell people whether that's
a template apply or
a function or applying a function it
right it's got to be one or the other i
i
why why isn't that a template string
template inside
applied to hash a
so you don't have the two string
oh it's my
screen so why don't i just write it
just be string template
of this thing here
we get rid of all of this nonsense
and we could say back to back tick
applied to hash a
like that
i see
yeah yeah yeah
yeah you can do that yeah of course you
can do that right
okay so my claim is that what you should
do is make a bunch of examples
yep
because i think it's going to be
honestly this thing with parameters is
it a fish is it does it jump out of the
water how does it work does it really
can it have an arbitrary thing in the
name what if you want to have unicode
characters in and
what if it's i it just seems incredibly
obscure to me
incredibly obscure the name you know
when is the name and name
you know do you call it if you say fish
does every time the word fish appears
does it substitute in fish gets
substituted with two string blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah that's right we
want this button this parameter slap
button
yeah because then anything you can it's
kind of like template input in doc
writing but it's
it's not
for docs it's to say this thing
this you know this should be okay so
the other possibility would be to use a
template notebook here that's a
well-developed technology
sure i think what we should do i do not
think this is a good idea i think this
is a giant
tail-chasing
exercise i think we either should have
them write code with good examples so
they can basically take an example that
is you know what we show them is
this is the finished question
this is what the code looks like and
they go click click and they have it
right
i think that's a very viable alternative
i think it's conceivable
that
um
we could offer them a template notebook
okay now i assume that why is the slot
thing
you know oh my gosh why are these not
lined up
could you screen capture avery could you
screen capture and show that to people
yep i got it
okay
so
here
this is exactly the slot that you're
looking for so to speak
isn't it yes
yes why don't we just use a template
notebook why don't we say just like for
your question pool you have a pop-up of
another notebook that is
specifying
your pool and where the diving board
goes and so on why don't we do the same
thing here but it's a template notebook
right we don't want to pull out we don't
want all the other tools we could we
just want to grab that slot button and
use the same
that technology are you sure
i mean
we don't want you know evaluate then
close cell behavior right that doesn't
mean no meaning that doesn't have any
meaning here no i agree um maybe
expression i i i
yes i think expression is relevant yeah
um
right we don't want it we don't want
everything here that'd just be confusing
slot and expression i think are the only
ones i'm not sure about this conditional
block i can imagine as well because it
depends on you know put bring out these
cells you know comment on this essay
you've got the blump you know a big
essay with a conditional block
i'm not sure about that but in any case
i really think this you know the attempt
to build this gui is is just just make
some nice examples and have them be
clean and use string templates and so on
make sense okay yeah
let's start with that
if we have a bunch of examples
and nobody can understand them
then
you know i think the next thing to go to
is a template notebook technology
i mean what are you doing with with your
parameter slot does it visually appear
different is it like a blob that shows
up there yeah we
there was going to be a visual indicator
we haven't spec that out yet yeah but
why not why why rebuild that whole
technology when we already have it for
template notebooks
that's a good point uh we'll look into
okay we're using the template notepad
stuff yep
okay what's next
uh so yeah we had a bunch of yeah not
nothing major but
you know minor
uh changes to the design
for these two new symbols
and so the ref pages have been updated
um they are still futurized even though
these are system symbols in thirteen one
so it'd be good to
uh un-futurize them
but experimentalize them yeah absolutely
um so you know before we had this thing
where we were mixing two associations
and it could have
been collisions
so we decided to use the
hash to approach for um
to pass assessment data in and that that
definitely cleaned things up we
implemented it remind me how that works
so
in question generator the second
argument is a function that returns a
question object yup and the arguments to
that function the first one is
the association that is you know the
driver and the second one
is
previous assessment results
okay which is an assessment result
object which can be nested and you can
query into it so i i think i think it'll
work well
right
okay
all right
that sounds okay to me
generation time
right that's not implemented that's more
of an idea than anything else okay fine
but it'd be good to revisit after after
the 13 one
you know i really don't like the name
question pool i really don't like it
bank is just as good but those are the
things that people call them in the in
the world that's what people call me the
question banks or question pools so
i wouldn't want anything
else
such an obscure name
i mean it's kind of like
what is it one is it's like a random
choice opera it's like a random choice
operator
oh god it's an operator like that so
question generator is an operator too is
that correct
yes
yeah you can think about that but yeah
look if it's an operator i i didn't even
understand that point i mean i wouldn't
even think yeah i mean you can call it
an upper but i wouldn't think of it as
like mapping input style but it's just
you know
a held thing that is
you know turned on by applying it to
arguments
i don't know i have different
connotation for the word operator but
functionally it's equivalent yeah i get
it
also the operator often will just
um
okay what does this go again so let's
see represents a question pool from
which
will be served
may maybe selected is a better word
oh no randomly selected i wouldn't
repeat it
random question object you will be
selected maybe no but but
also
represents a question pool
it won't be it's not will be served
from which it can be served it can be
served it's not will be there's no will
be possible nothing's going to happen in
this case
represents a question pool
from which one of the question objects
qosabai and i would spell out question
objects not that not that not the
function name from what from which one
of the question objects queues from
which
from which question objects qo sub i
can be randomly selected
yep
cloud deploy should have a hyphen
um
not returns this selected question
returns the first note there returns a
randomly selected question object
yes
and then returns a list of n
randomly selected objects question
objects
okay
okay
um
what else is there to look at here
except this name are we going with banks
or pools
i prefer pool i wouldn't be upset about
bank
let's see if we if we just do a little
search on the web yeah i've done that
experiment before
that's why i read that's why i slightly
prefer pools because of
incognito google searches
uh
question bank wins by a factor of
100
in terms of of number of hits
question pool is like half a million
hits question bank is like like 42
million hits
in my mind question bank has a slightly
different connotation i think
just because question bank is usually
like
it's one thing
that like you go to the question bank
like website or whatever where you
answer questions from their specific
bank whereas question pool is more like
an individual thing that's interesting i
got 3.6 billion for question pool and
two billion question bank
well i mean those numbers are just
nonsense anyway oh yeah my numbers are
different also yeah
it's an estimate
did you use quotes
i i did question space pool and question
space paying no you just have to use
quotes
well if if
look
okay
yeah maybe question bank yeah
you know what what about question
selector
just you've got question generator
questions select or
one of them is just selecting and the
other is generating
what do you feel about that because then
it then it goes along with question
generator
because i don't think it's people think
like select like pattern matching or
anything do you
no i don't
in my mind
teachers are familiar with the with the
pool yes except that they mean something
different by it yeah as you've said
question bank i mean you see question
pool to me is exactly what the web is
telling me it means that is a question
bank
there's a definition here question bank
is a collection of questions that is
stored for repeated use
that's what i would have expected right
that's exactly what i would expected not
a local selector
a question bank is kind of like well
we're going to set this test
this week now we're going to use these
five questions once kaboom selenium well
i mean you could take one of these
things and you know export it and
yes but that's not what you have in mind
you haven't well we also have this idea
of uh coursework repository where it's
exactly what we have in mind no no but
it's not what you have in mind for this
question pool object you have in mind a
select at the moment of generating the
quiz
different for each student
yeah that's your whole point
whereas this other thing is much more of
a global thing where go to the bank
select the things everybody's going to
get the same five questions
like i mean i mean the idea was that you
would take one of these question pool
objects and you would
publish it in a repository and somebody
else could bring it down and i know that
you really deploy it in their quiz right
now
but it but you're saying that the the
use case of generator and selector which
is what it should be called
is at the moment of quiz generation run
it
right correct right
right we have this generation time thing
that we want to do but yeah
well i think question selector is much
better i think it's clear what it does
it selects between questions question
generator generates questions you should
yeah
just i think we need to use the terms
quickly in the documentation
for seo yeah other things
bank and pool
yeah it's fine you can do that but i
mean you put them in the keywords
my only other thing to add is that
question pools and in like blackboard
and d2l
are
the way that we have
question pools in here it's great then
people will learn that that's what we
call a question selector
the fact that somebody else named
something somewhere and possibly got it
wrong and confuse people is irrelevant
let's call it question selector it's the
right thing it goes with question
generator it goes with question object
it's more will for me
yeah it's more it's more something that
people will understand in our code
i mean otherwise they're going to be
confused you know we can absolutely have
question banks
in the courseware repository they'll be
great there but they're not what you're
talking about here
so i mean when you retrieve a question
bank it
will have head question selector i
imagine no it won't most of the time it
will be something with no no because
what you want to do is you want to go to
the question bank and you want to
retrieve five questions once and for all
for your quiz
right so that your authoring notebook
has i think the typical use case will be
retrieve your questions from the
question bank then annotate them a bit
in your quiz
then use your quiz
rather than
this which is at the moment of
individually generating it for a
particular student
make a new quiz item make make a new
question see what i'm saying
no i bet i think this is both this is
both things
well i don't think it should be both
things
i don't think it should be i don't think
that's the right way to use it
i think that there's a separate piece of
machinery which is going from the
repository to here
that you're not going to want to do that
you're going to want to see you're not
going to want something i mean think
about the scenario okay so here's my
scenario i'm going to set
a thing with five questions
right it reminds me i've just been
writing this stuff about the creation of
the nks book where we use director plate
printing okay where there were no proofs
like it's just the bits go to the direct
plate machine a plate is made then the
plate is printed from
okay
you're not going to want that here
you're not going to go going to go
straight for unless you're feeling very
rushed or lazy or something as a teacher
you're not going to want to go straight
from the question bank without seeing
what actual questions have been picked
for your students
and have them run well i mean you can
review them as a selector
right but the selector selects at random
each time only once it's deployed right
it's not it's not no but you don't want
to do that for a selector you want every
student in the class to get the same
five questions but those well that's not
that's not what you that's not what a
bank in a pool typically are used for
yes but it is that's where you're wrong
a question bank
is used as this definition on the web
says a question bank is there's 300
questions here okay you're going to
make a quiz you're going to pick five
questions usually by computer sometimes
by hand out of those 300 questions those
will be your quiz picked once and for
all
they're not picked at the moment when an
individual quiz is peeled off for a
particular i think the common use is
that different students are serve
different questions you know it's here
you know here's a hundred questions that
are you know what his word
says in moodle the question bank allows
a teacher to create preview and edit
questions in a database and use them in
the quiz or lesson activity
exactly what i just said
question bank next next thing here is a
free tool which allows you to create
practice questions from thousands of
past question papers
it's exactly the use that i'm describing
every single one of these says the use
that i'm describing
i've got yeah there's more here
create preview and edit
are you sharing something or i wasn't
sharing this no i mean it's just web
results
every single one says what says it the
way that i'm saying not it is selected
randomly for a student at the moment
when the student presses the button
yeah look at this i mean uh here i'll
show you
i'm i'll show you i'll show you what i
have here every single one question bank
allows teachers to preview questions we
go down here you know
sap suite question bank provides
educators with access to 3 500 questions
which can be exported for use in
curricular instructional planning
this is all exactly the use that i
thought it was which is you've got a set
of questions you pick from those
questions probably as a human
you select from those questions then you
go and you put them on your test
it is not what you're saying
what you're saying is a different thing
which is at the moment when a test is
made for an individual student pick a
random question that's a different
activity
look at this
question bank for survey monkey contains
hundreds of questions
every single one of these it's as i've
described it like teachers do want to
have each i don't care
you told me it was called a bank and
it's not called a bank i told you it's
called a pool okay well let's look up
question pool let's see what those say
no
it's not saying it's not question pools
serve as the basis for random draw
questions to give each student
okay so look the first results are set
of questions identify by name and share
a question pool with other set of
questions we go
collection of questions stored for
repeated use
to obtain a question blah blah blah blah
blah blah
question poem was at least 10 times the
number of questions for a single exam
okay the question pulls inside i mean
that implies that they're not all in the
exam right so that one is the first one
the other ones are the other ones aren't
saying anything about holidays but they
don't mean it they don't mean it's
randomly selected they don't mean that
okay but this one's here
i'm sorry i'm not buying it it's just
not what these people are seeing here
okay these ones i admit down here these
pools are more used at random okay down
here but question bank is definitely not
yeah
okay let's just not go here let's just
call it question selector and if we if
we do want
um
i just don't want you to think i'm
bullshitting you because question pool
is used this way i can see that it is
used this way okay thank you for thank
you for clarifying that okay yeah
okay i'm i'm seeing avery's pointing out
the black ball calls it a random block
we can't make that today
[Laughter]
it's also a bad name but um
i mean maybe we should have the word
random in there
randomized question which is what we're
planning to call it in the text
well apparently in their new
thing they're calling the random block
random block and question set are both
now called question pool for blackboard
they're not using those terminology
i think question selector is okay how
does the random seeding work for that
it's just using random choice so if
you've done
seed random then it'll work
um
at the moment of generating the test
yes
okay yes
so i mean if it's deployed in api
obviously you have no control and you
shouldn't
the student has no control
the student has no control
right because the seating is all
happening in the cloud api the cloud
kernel
yes that's fine right otherwise you can
have a very strange
kind of um
gaming right exactly yeah yeah
i'd be impressed by the person who
figured that out but we still don't want
to allow it
get an a in the computer security class
exactly exactly
too bad too bad this was french history
[Music]
the
um
okay all right that looks good anything
else i'm running out of time that was
our agenda we covered it
excellent okay i mean this is nice
functionality it's really and i i'm
going to be interested to see
you know as we build this wall from
language learning capability which i
hope is happening um you know obviously
we should be using this
yeah
and um that's the first great use case
and i really would like to see that i
mean you're going to have this you know
in time for our summer camp for example
i want to have built a bunch of stuff
there which we can test
and then maybe we can actually build
some stuff in real time from this
sure are you doing camp this year
i'm not doing camp this year okay
you'll be missed
um
all right talk to you also